russia's invasion of ukraine has shocked
and appalled the west u.s president joe
biden has condemned the attack as
unjustified and unprovoked this is a
pre-meditated attack this president
putin was bringing war back to europe
innumerable missiles and bombs have been
raining down on an entirely innocent
population
but the reaction in china has been much
more ambiguous
xi jinping and vladimir putin are closer
than ever
and while china won't endorse the war
it won't condemn it either the results
of this un security council resolution
three abstentions china india and the
united arab emirates
so what does china really think about
russia's invasion
and could she help putin win the war in
ukraine
[Music]
we will never know whether he warned
that there was going to be a military
operation there is reporting which the
chinese deny fiercely that
they asked putin to wait until after the
olympics were over so as not to ruin the
beijing winter olympics it is true that
if you talk to foreign diplomats who met
the chinese either at the united nations
in new york or in beijing on the day of
the invasion that at least chinese
diplomats seemed surprised they didn't
have a line ready to take they had not
prepared
the evacuation of chinese citizens
living in ukraine but that doesn't mean
that xi jinping didn't know because the
truth is that in the chinese system the
really tough decisions are taken at the
top of the communist party and the
diplomats and chinese embassies are way
lower down the totem pole
so the chinese official version is that
they are neutral that china is a
peace-loving country that it takes very
seriously everyone's territorial
integrity and sovereignty including
ukraine so that's the official
high-minded benevolent china line the
problem is that it's a pseudo-neutrality
it is a pro-russian anti-american
pseudo-neutrality they say that the war
is the fault of america it's the fault
of nato for expanding to russia's
borders that russia has every right to
want to live in a secure europe with its
own security guarantees and
china's extremely strictly censored
state media has been putting out
basically russian propaganda if you're
chinese and watching state tv or looking
at the heavily centered internet here
you would believe that russian troops
are behaving with extraordinary
restraint that they are there to
dislodge nazis from ukraine and that the
americans are the ones pouring fuel on
the fire by sending new arms into this
war because the americans want this war
to drag on because they want suffering
to help them dismantle russia for kind
of cold war reasons
[Music]
that's two good questions and they have
slightly different answers china doesn't
want this war china doesn't like chaos
china is bound into all kinds of global
supply chains it does very very nicely
out of a kind of stable commercial
trading order so are they delighted that
vladimir putin invaded ukraine no
they're not you can tell because at one
level they're not even admitting that
it's an invasion they won't use the word
because they don't like the idea that
this is an invasion and a war started by
russia could they benefit from it um it
may be shocking as we see images of
women and children being killed in the
streets of ukraine but there are already
chinese scholars out in the state media
saying how this could work out nicely
for china not least because america
which they see as their big rival is
going to be distracted and tied up in
europe leaving america less time to come
and interfere in china's backyard in
asia
[Music]
so if you are sitting in taiwan watching
this war far away in ukraine you do have
a reason to worry because when vladimir
putin says that ukraine isn't a proper
country it's actually part of russia you
might remember chinese leaders saying
that taiwan is not a country it's just a
province of china that needs to come
back to the motherland you might also be
watching to see how much america and its
allies are able to influence putin's
thinking are the sanctions are the
weapons supplies enough to make putin
stay his hand and leave ukraine because
america above all is the security
guarantee for taiwan that if china
attacks one day america will either help
them or even turn up and fight alongside
them does this mean that xi jinping is
going to speed up his attack on taiwan i
think if you're a pessimist you would
say if he thinks america's looking weak
then
that is an encouragement to go for it
soon if you're an optimist then you
would say russia is suffering the most
extraordinarily painful sanctions and
the fight isn't going brilliantly for
the russian military even if they end up
winning one day and so if you're china
maybe you're looking at that and
thinking
this is a tougher fight than perhaps we
were expecting maybe there's more
resistance waiting for us than we'd
hoped and they're looking at these
sanctions how much damage to these
worldwide sanctions from america and its
allies inflict on russia because that
should give china pause for thought
china is a very cautious power it's a
new superpower it is not going to come
to
russia's aid militarily not least you
know china has all these shiny new
weapons but it hasn't fought a war since
the late 1970s and that was a brief war
with vietnam that it lost so they're
gonna not come to the rescue militarily
i don't even think they're gonna come
and mediate and have some grand peace
conference because everyone knows
they're on russia's side they're not
neutral the one area that russia will be
hoping for help i think is that as these
sanctions imposed by america and its
allies bite really hard on the russian
economy russia's only hope its only
friend with deep pockets is china and so
russia is going to be hoping that china
buys more oil and gas buys more russian
wheat buys more russian kind of minerals
but if the russians are hoping that
china disobeys the sanctions and
actually helps russia cheat then i think
they may be disappointed because at the
end of the day china is an exceptionally
self-interested power and it will always
look out for china's interests and that
doesn't mean
getting chinese banks and chinese
companies sanctioned
[Music]
i think if we saw
a sort of massive escalation if this
looked like tipping into a world war if
this looked like you know god forbid
using kind of chemical weapons or even
small tactical nuclear weapons which is
one of the kind of fears out there i
think china would find that very very
disturbing remember that china's journey
to supremacy china's rise is based on
being
the place that manufactures stuff and
sells for export america and europe are
between them the most important market
for chinese goods so if this really got
out of control perhaps china might not
be as upset as we might hope by lots of
people being killed in the streets of
ukraine but the chinese economy would go
into a tailspin
if the world really fell off a cliff
china is watching and waiting and trying
to stay out of trouble and to calculate
how to take advantage of this but if
anyone is expecting china to come to the
rescue
either with its armies or even with its
diplomacy then i'm afraid they're going
to be disappointed china is all about
china's interests and it's not going to
change particularly when the world is in
an incredibly dangerous state
china is really clear that it's a
friendship with no limits
that china and russia see the world in
very similar ways when it comes to you
know the wickedness of democracies
criticizing uh one party systems or also
autocrats um but they don't want an
alliance why because alliance is kind of
a technical promise that if someone
attacks your ally that you will go and
fight for them and
putin is proving the chinese right when
they thought russia is actually just too
fond of adventures
and you know invading other countries
for us to want to be bound
in anything like an alliance so
it's not an alliance is this the
beginning of a world order you know it
could be and one of the interesting
things here in beijing is when i talk to
ambassadors and diplomats and chinese
scholars they're very clear about just
what a big moment this is this is china
showing its hand
although it's officially neutral no one
believes it's neutral for a minute they
are an anti-american pro-russian power
that is tearing up decades of chinese
caution this is a moment uh for for
china and russia two giant autocracies
to have each other's backs in a kind of
historic
struggle with america and to basically
say that the entire rules-based order
put in place after the second world war
no longer works for china and russia and
they are willing to challenge it pretty
much openly that is a huge moment and we
don't know how this story ends
to read more about how china views the
crisis in ukraine click the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe